[Music]
new Star Wars movie force awakens opens
this week we're all very excited about
it no I'm not but anyway go ahead I'm so
excited I had the moon on our set
replaced with the Death Star isn't that
cool check it out that's awesome not
need this for the week we put this up
about two hours ago and I understand
that producer Jordan slansky has a
problem with it let's bring him out here
Jordan boo hate-mail hi George a dick hi
Jordan who would tolerate him in a
marriage oh boo and orange got something
on his schedule today George we went to
great trouble to make this Death Star I
understand you you you have a comment
you'd like to make is that true well I
appreciate the effort in terms of
accuracy there are some significant
issues okay what do you mean what's
what's wrong with it their chopper well
the first glaring error is the size of
the Death Star you depicted it being
exactly the same size as the moon that
normally hangs in the backdrop which
poses a problem if the Death Star fires
its primary weapon the super laser the
incredibly tight orbit effectively
removes the option to fire the weapon
which would laughably be in a tactical
error it simply wouldn't happen it's
basically saying the Death Star should
be smaller well the second major
inconsistency is the lack of a middle
ring within the large concave dish on
the dishes northern hemisphere the third
complaint pertains to the width
why did he run away on camera alright
alright got away just in time Jordan
you're safe right that's the thing about
the Death Star once you see that laser
coming fast can't say something
go kill him her Lola Marla oh yeah I
didn't kill him earlier and I've always
felt that way I never know that its main
its big weapon is called the super laser
what a good name for it
you